stephen evans is from the london school
of hygiene and tropical medicine who
joins us now
uh to ponder on this professor thanks
for your time this lunch time
um v-day it's been dubbed and we keep
talking about the
logistical challenges that's that's
almost trite isn't it in a sense it's
more than that it's administrative
it's bureaucratic it's writing to
hundreds of thousands of people
and making sure they've got the the
cards that prove they've had the jab
i think that proving they've had the jab
is not
the key element to this what is
vital is that people are reminded and
when you get to my age and older
you do need reminders on occasions and
being reminded of when you go back to
your second dose because your
protection after one dose will be there
but not as effective as it will be after
two doses
i think the idea that you can guarantee
that you are
immune if you are infected
with the virus having been vaccinated
is simply not true you
have a very good chance of not getting
the disease
but you still will have a 5 to 10
percent
possibly more we don't know for certain
what the efficacy will be
when it's rolled out to people in
practice
in the trials everything is done
perfectly
out there in the big wide world things
sometimes don't go
quite perfectly so this is extremely
good news
but let's not be complacent there will
be those as you say who simply forget
to go for that second job there'll be
others of course and we've seen some
survey data recently probably suggesting
that anything up to 20
of the uk population remains skeptical
about the necessity of a job
how do we go about persuading those
those people who are skeptical about
whether they actually need the job or
not well
my personal view is that we shouldn't
make this compulsory that
will reduce confidence if anything in my
view
but that's a very personal view i think
you have to
try and get people to listen to the
evidence
and the clear evidence we have here
is that there are no serious adverse
effects to this vaccine
when we have studied it in more than
10 000 people who've been vaccinated
one of the things that's happened in the
trials is that there was at least
one death in the trial
fortunately in some senses but very sad
for the individual of course and their
family
but fortunately it happened to be in the
placebo group the person who didn't get
the vaccine
and so we're going to see over the
coming days and weeks we will have
reports of deaths following the
vaccination
will be strokes there'll be heart
attacks because we're
vaccinating a very vulnerable population
that's why we're doing it because they
are at risk of
dying from covid19 but sadly they're
also
at risk of dying from other things so
one of the key things will be getting
people's understanding
that lots of these adverse effects are
merely coincidence
we saw this with mmr and autism that
when you vaccinate people at around the
age that they get autism
diagnosed then you get a coincidence of
vaccination followed by autism and we'll
see that again
but the right way to do it is to ask
people
where their evidence is that it's
harmful
trace back the source of that evidence
and see whether it's reliable and trace
back the source of evidence
that says that it is safe that we have
searched for harms
and not found them we can't guarantee
perfect safety in the sense that there
are zero horns people will get sore
arms and sometimes those sore arms will
last a while and they'll
end up in some pain for a little while
but not very long it will usually go
away
pretty rapidly they may have a high
temperature and that may last
a day or two but very shortly after that
they will get the benefit they will also
have those same things after a second
dose and it
it may even be that the rate at which it
occurs is slightly greater after a
second dose
we don't know fully but we're going to
learn a lot
and so the key thing in terms of the
bureaucracy in my view
is that we are able to trace who gets
the vaccine
who gets which batch of the vaccine and
that should be on these cards
and we need to have that data getting
back into the gp's record
and the plans for doing that are really
well advanced
it's very likely that those who get
vaccinated tomorrow
will have that knowledge in their gp
record on wednesday
and that is going to be very important
for the follow-up
yeah and that would be quite a feat
wouldn't it professor stephen evans
appreciate your time thanks a lot
thank you